oh my God Chloe oh my god with is the
last time you better answer me you're
doing great okay your eyes are watering
hey hey you're crying I'm not crying
you're not Kris Jenner's enjoying the
high life on the latest episode of the
Kardashians literally cheers to Palm
Springs Palm Springs love you guys
Three's Company come and knock at my
door just tuned in because you never
know what's gonna happen the highlights
well the mamajour's adventure kicked off
after buying over 700 of weed products
with her daughter Chloe and boyfriend
Corey Gamble go boy but it's all for
medical purposes right now we're headed
to a dispensary because my right leg and
hip have been driving me crazy I sleep
in pain and it seems to get worse and
worse and worse I'm just trying to maybe
get some relief it smells like a crazy
party in here to be honest kind of like
the 70s turns out this isn't Chris's
first rodeo have you ever seen your mom
High yes okay so talk about what Kris
Jenner is like hi
so Coco won't spill but uh We've
definitely seen a loopy crisp before
it's never a dull moment remember when
the mom of six had some fun eating weed
gummy bears with her mom MJ you're a
good cook
I didn't cook the popcorn
so MJ's feeling really good right now
because we're trying out a new remedy
for her back pain what's her remedy well
yeah seems like history
why don't you just give me that yeah
we'll start here I'll put it in my purse
so am I going to get arrested if I have
this in my purse no and I'll take it if
you get scared I don't care it was hers
your honor let's just say it didn't take
long for things to kick in Chloe when's
the last time that you had
an all-girls night an all girls night
yeah like just let it
oh
oh my God Chloe when's the last
[Music]
the gummies have clearly kicked in with
my mom
the end of the day Chris is high hijinks
are just what Chloe needed amid all her
drama with her ex Tristan Thompson I
love when my family is silly and
light-hearted and they can all laugh at
themselves and I can laugh with them
like this is what life is just
ah the fun relaxed nature of it all this
is my happy place
I can tell you one thing for sure I am
not feeling any pain in my hip right now
not a thing I do love you
I do love you too
[Music]